[Music]
welcome
to the iron lords podcast
hello everyone and welcome my name is
pete also known as naldo here to give
you guys a first look
at this amazing game called pile up from
handy games
now uh i took a little bit of time on uh
on saturday night um i wanted to really
really play this game
uh and i thought it was a really really
great concept i
really love these team strategy type
games
so uh what i wanted to do was i wanted
to see if my wife would want
to uh to join me and play so we ended up
taking some time together and
uh what we decided to do was we ended up
deciding to play it
and uh this game was way more fun that i
i
expected um i it seemed very very plain
originally when i saw all the the
graphics and all the preliminary um
stuff involving the game
so i thought oh how how you know
exciting could this game be
but the end result was that it was a lot
more exciting than i
expected so what ended up happening was
that many times um
throughout the whole entire game uh let
me let me take a step back and tell you
a little bit about it um
you play as a box and what you're
looking to do is you're looking to go
through this world that has been
destroyed
and and rebuild it now um through this
time what
i ended up doing was i ended up playing
as this box um
and my wife ended up playing as a box
and we
had to do puzzles to get through each
part of the map
to get to the next part and while you're
going through you can pick up
golden bricks and also circular
almost looks like a spring uh or i think
it's like some type of masking tape or
something like that
which would make sense i think it's
masking tape and you go throughout the
levels and then you'd pick up this area
and you'd eventually complete the
end puzzle which would allow you to get
a key which would open up your next
world and you'd be able to go through
that
now we played um only one level
and it was almost um an
hour and a half uh i think a little
longer than that
and it didn't feel like an hour and a
half
uh it was a lot of fun uh the controls
were fantastic
i loved how the game felt i love how the
movement worked we played with both with
the controllers
i don't know how it would be with a
keyboard and mouse but
i knew that i wanted to use a controller
for this type of game because i've
played these types of games before
and i knew that the controller would be
the preferred method and they actually
have a pop-up that says that
when you log into the game you know
controller is your preferred method
so we went through um a lot of this game
and i only am showing you a little bits
of it because
uh i didn't want to give you the full
amount of everything we did
so you're gonna see a little bit of the
tutorial as we're going through
so things we were learning uh some of
the cool abilities that we learned
and then after that we ended up doing
some more of the larger
portions of it of the map where they're
a little more complicated
and i think that the game is great
it's four player couch co-op uh i don't
know if you do it over
over the net uh we weren't able to test
that uh
it was amazing i l i
real i can't tell you how much i loved
it uh the graphics on it were fun
they were you know uplifting there
wasn't
anything too crazy about it uh the
replay value on it the puzzles
are very very intricate uh
the for the longer longer you play now
this is just a first look video because
myself and
uh my wife wanted to to play it for a
little bit but
uh with her being pregnant we she didn't
want to sit uh too long but we're
planning on finishing it
so we're gonna end up trying to complete
more of it and play throughout
and see how that goes now
there's a couple of different things i
just wanted to bring to your attention
while you're playing this if this is the
first time you're looking at this game
um
there are regular bot you are a box
you can move boxes you can end up
moving um what's it called these springs
uh which will allow you to jump along
larger and higher
and then you also have these things
called they're almost like
um tongue boxes which you jump on the
top
a tongue shoots out and it lets you grab
certain things or grab other people
and there's times where we were just
messing around playing and we were just
doing that to each other like
my wife would get in the way i would
just hit her with the with the tongue
box and pull her back and then she'd get
mad at me and we would laugh
because it was it was a very playful
game there was there
didn't seem to be anything really
violent or competitive because it was
all
cooperative play as for
the end when we completed it uh we ended
up completing
uh the first map we got almost
everything in the first world
um you were able to unlock um this
portion called the lighthouse
and we checked the lighthouse out and
that was really cool a little bit of
spoilers
uh but i don't want to give you any
information on it just just know it's
pretty cool
to go through and we ended up doing that
and then we went back to the
to the original world and we learned
that you unlocked um
like a party game in an arcade and you
went into the arcade and you could end
up uh doing other things in there
and and what was in this arcade was it
was almost like this soccer tournament
so we would end up uh playing against
each other and we do this
soccer tournament back and forth back
and forth and it worked out really
really well and it was a lot of fun
uh definitely fun for more players um
not just the two of us
so that was really really neat uh i
really like that
and um yeah i think uh if you guys are
looking for a little couch co-op
game uh you know definitely go ahead and
pick a pile it up
or i should say pile up um from handy
games thank you very much for giving us
uh this key it was really really great
uh the developer is
seed by seed uh i would definitely go uh
take a look and and see how it is and
play it for yourselves but i would say
that this is one of one of those games
that
i really really enjoyed i would compare
it to you know an overcooked
you know it's one of those party games
that you're going to love playing over
and over again
and it's going to get more complicated i
cannot wait to see how
much more complicated it gets i'm hoping
that we get into finishing this and
actually give you guys a review video
soon so
alrighty thank you very much everybody
and make sure you guys check out the
arnold's podcast
which is on on sunday nights all right
thank you i should say sunday days uh or
sunday nights
uh depending upon what is happening
throughout the week all right well thank
you very much everybody
have a fantastic day and i will talk to
you all soon thank you
[Music]
so
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
do
do
so
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
so
so
so
this
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
you